joining me now is vince everett ellison
author of the new book 25 lies and amela
at pinobi prageru personality vince how
insulting
is this whole racket to you personally
well laura your mama log was straight up
i mean it was right on the money uh the
declarative statement in my new book 25
lies i started by saying since its
inception in 1800 because of slavery the
confederacy and jim crow
the democratic party
has been the evilest institution on the
face of this earth
and this is why it's because they lie
they say that racism is a cause of all
of our problems that is a lie
people that believe in white supremacy
must also believe in black inferiority
you can't have both of them and as a
black man i can tell you i don't believe
in white supremacy because as an heir of
jesus christ and the son of god i have
never met anyone superior to me i have
brothers and sisters
they all have talents and that's all i
need a good people with talents given to
them by god that we try that we have to
elevate and if we elevate each other's
talents we all elevate each other all of
society becomes elevated
but the democrats want hatred they want
envy they want strife they live on it
they've always had it from slavery civil
war
jim crow now now socialism they want us
to hate one another and they live off of
the hate and this is why i call them an
evil institution
you know my book talks about 25 lives
that they give they talk about their
evil it talks about what they do wrong
talk about how we drive how they drive
all of us against one another and this
is just another example this is racial
propaganda all right amel i want to go
back to this showtime fiasco this i i
think it's racist this dude so-called
docuseries here's one of what they call
one of their comedians heavily featured
whiteness is a construct created only to
oppress and they use the privilege that
comes out of that construct to give
access for other people who don't have
that privilege if your black friends
aren't talking to you about how white
people are it's probably because you
are a white person not a person who
happens to be white and they are also
not really your black friends so
remember that
amelia some of these folks are
incredibly privileged they make an
enormous amount of money for spouting
illogical nonsense
uh and
travel the country selling these you
know racial hectoring and all these
kinds of ideas that obviously aren't
helping a single person get a better job
or a better opportunity
so how do you reason with someone like
that as a young person
it's very difficult we're in a day and
age now where oppression is currency and
you can get a large amount of fame and
and support for spouting these lies and
this propaganda i did so for quite some
time and it's just ridiculous as far as
reasoning i say look at the results of
the policies that they advocate for of
the campaigns that they're running
defunding the police decriminalizing
shoplifting allowing drug abuse in our
streets specifically here in california
progressive policy has been the bane of
the existence of lower income people in
in the communities of color in this
state so you have to look at the results
here i'm hearing a whole lot of talk
about racism and what that does is it
takes away from the true hearts of these
issues like class like two-parent
households like resources like education
and when we sit and look at these issues
and look at the disparate impact on
people of color and scream nothing but
racism we take away from the actual
solutions at hand in actually addressing
these problems it's truly disgusting to
watch this showtime special well they
they want to switch the topic because
they're failing
minority communities every single day in
this country and they know it and i
think they know that more minority
voters are seeing the light on this as
well and i think they're freaking out
vince over at msnbc today a fordham
university professor
proposed something as a topic for a
family meeting watch
you need to sit your family members down
and explain to them the threat that the
republican party faces to american
democracy walk them through the white
nationalist road we are on with this
particular party they're more than
willing to take this entire country off
of a financial cliff an environmental
cliff a civil rights cliff you name it
vince apparently nothing's changed in
the united states since the segregation
is south and maybe since the early days
of the civil war
the democrat party has been in charge of
the black community for 220 years
i was born on a cotton plantation in
howard county tennessee my father was a
sharecropper he bought us out of poverty
and after college i started working in a
prison i know the democrat party very
very well
they run every crack house every
prostitute house every failing school
every big city mayor every big city
police chief every judge and jury that
locks up black men is run by the
democrat party if you don't believe me
go to any ghetto in america and walk
around it see if you see any white
republicans anywhere you're going to run
into black democrats all over the place
and you're going to run into the most
black preachers most black politicians
and most black civic organizers and
they're the ones that are doing the
conduit they are the conduits for the
democratic party
this is them this is the democrat party
and all they do is is is moment hate
that's what they do and they live off of
it but black people aren't crazy they
understand
in our bible when cain was angry because
god had rejected his offering he said if
you do well
will you not be accepted
and if not sin waits at the door to
master you but you must master it
the democrats
are not after the fallen they already
have fallen
and they don't know this but they are
already defeated
amla the left is racializing everyday
activities i mean
everything is racist
it seems like it sometimes even picking
an emoji
according to npr jennifer epperson from
houston identifies as black and said she
changed her approach depending on who
she was talking to i use the default
emoji the yellow toned one for
professional settings then i use the
dark brown emoji for friends and family
i just don't have the emotional capacity
to unpack race relations in the
professional setting
envelope
you think of the underground railroad
and you think of rosa parks and now
we're at
emojis
right it's it's completely ridiculous
and when you view the world through the
lens of racism you will find it
everywhere it's how i used to view the
world and every cross look and every
color emoji was had racism in it and
that's how they operate and we really
have to deviate from that because it's a
disservice to everybody who learns this
sort of ideology there are young
children now being taught in school that
their race matters more than who they
are as an individual what their
interests are what their dislikes are
their merit their character and if we
continue on this route we're going to
have a generation that is completely
crippled by this narrative who cares
what color your emojis are and you
should question anybody who looks at you
and tries to convince you of your own
victimhood and you should ask what do
they get from me being convinced of this
and when you've answered that question
you'll find that you should not be on
their side yeah how much do they make
from selling victimhood and racializing
everything around us vince amela
wonderful to see both of you tonight hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else